thank you for talking with us so it
sounds like we're characterizing the
role of philanthropy to be this
catalytic investor that then makes
impact investing feasible once it has
once a an idea has been shown to be
productive but and then impact investing
is interested in addressing these ideas
these generally goods and services ideas
that are able to produce a profit and
produce social impact but what about
those areas philanthropy like malaria
for example where there is no possible
way of creating a social impact
investment I guess what I mean is so
there are these companies that are
producing bed nets and there are people
who need them they're able to purchase
them and that is earning money and
creating social good and that's great
there are many many more people who
either because of lack of education or
because of simple lack of funds are in
dire need of these nets but are not
purchasing them how is it's not a case
where it is appropriate for
philanthropists to invest in a goods and
service type project in order to address
the sheer lack of a business model to
address the problem I mean I I couldn't
agree with you more I think that I think
that there are cases like the one that
you you raised where what has come to be
known as the impact investing model be
at private equity or debt or whatever
simply is not going to apply I mean
there are and perhaps isn't something
that we don't really want to look at in
the face but I believe that there are
certain social goods and public goods
that perhaps the market and private
enterprise in this sense is never going
to be able to address in the way that
you you know that we might hope so I
don't think it's appropriate for all
sectors and problems I actually grew
with you but Stevens Point poses a
paradox if in fact there are businesses
that are reaping profits by engaging in
the production and distribution of bed
nets
wouldn't philanthropic engagement with
an undercut those businesses how can you
convince a consumer I can get this for
free why should I pay you as a business
social venture business or whatever for
the same thing I can get for free but
look in here the consumers in most of
these goods before they get to the end
user they're the World Health
Organization's of this world and so on
so i think is that you know this is a
little bit more complicated in that but
ya know got me fair point and fair
paradox um the concert i have the
opposite of that one it's yeah Steven to
to your point i would say that there are
many regions of the world that have just
not yet been reached by those
organizations that are handing out free
bed nets and if i'm a person living in
that organization then and i see that
i'm not getting a free bed net it only
makes sense to purchase one and while
the facts remain is there i don't think
that philanthropic efforts to get free
bed nets and some people are
undercovering the possibility for impact
where people just are not yet getting
those but nuts no but I mean your butt
but your previous statements sort of
implies that the person in question has
sufficient disposable income that they
can make a choice that they will they
will buy or they won't buy well there's
not a free ones i'm going to buy i'll
buy one show any i think it varies from
person to person it sounded like
Professor Thorne was suggesting that
there are such people who would then
choose not to because they could later
get a free one mmm that right yes isn't
that I mean there are examples of that
ya know and that's a problem but I mean
I think it's the engagement of sort of
NGOs and philanthropy and so on in that
manner is is deeply problematic because
for two reasons one the displacing the
displacement effect which you're talking
about the two and this is rivoli aside
of it as the motivations